pour certains albertain la vie est une
course sans fin quand ce n'est pas au
travail c'est dans des centres comme
celui ci qu'il brûle les calories c'est
souvent justement dans ce club privé du
centre-ville de calgary et que guérir ce
n'est dans lequel robertson rencontrent
leurs clients ces deux analystes suivent
depuis des années le rythme effréné
auquel se développe le secteur pétrolier
albertain
même si le baril pétrole a perdu la
moitié de sa valeur en quelques mois il
prédit qu'il faudra être patient avant
de voir une réduction significative de
la production énergétique en alberta
comme quoi quand on court très vite
s'arrêter prend du temps
dans l'ouest canadien et ce sont trois
millions et demi de baril de pétrole qui
sont extraits du sol chaque jour un
nombre qui est appelé à augmenter au
cours des prochaines années
l'industrie s'attend à ce que la
croissance de la production ralentit un
peu par rapport aux prévisions de l'an
dernier et s'il y aura tout de même une
augmentation de la production pour les
deux prochaines années au moins dans les
sables bitumineux 33 milliards de
dollars ont été investis l'année
dernière seulement une immense homme qu
il faut rentabiliser
c'est difficile pour eux d'arrêter il ya
de l'argent qui est investi
on a commencé à creuser quelque chose
dépend des roues on est rendu dans le
processus
on peut pas juste arrêter cette analyse
de financier comprend la difficulté
qu'ont les entreprises pétrolières à
diminuer la cadence
selon lui pas besoin d'être un géant de
l'énergie pour avoir les mêmes réflexes
financier que les entreprises qui
exploitent les sables bitumineux à
chaque maison on n'achète pas je peux
juste n'a permettre pour un an
même son passé une mauvaise passe on va
essayer de la garder aussi longtemps
qu'on peut puis on a un âge certain
d'optimisme que même si les choses ont
vraiment mal
on va se trouver un nouvel emploi si on
a perdu notre emploi à calgary
l'analyste guiraud la scène et son
collègue dans une robe ericsson sont
convaincus que les entreprises devront
diminuer tôt ou tard leur production
pour assurer leur survie
guy de la scène estime que les prix la
ressource pourrait encore chuter parce
que même si le canada n'est qu'un joueur
dans la compétition si ni lui ni ses
adversaires ne diminuent leurs
productions l'offre de pétrole
continuera d'être élevé les grandes
pétrolières qui font encore des profits
sont elles prêtes à ralentir rapidement
l'exploitation
difficile à dire dans une province où
même l'hiver n'empêche pas certains de
courir ici raphaël bouvier auclair radio
canada qu'elle garait